[Musique]
Les héros c'est une notion démodée de Den
mais le monde peut toujours
les utiliser prêts quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il en
coûte nous avons détruit
Thanos mais ce n'est pas fini mon travail est
inévitable il faudra toujours
plus finir
que
ce n'est que le
début elle a déchiré un  trou dans
l'espace, il y a une
réalité différente menant à la
[Musique]
la nôtre, qu'es-tu prêt à faire je suis
petit, tes pouvoirs ne font que me rendre plus fort, tu
vois, ça ne peut pas être égalé, la
[Musique]
ne peut pas être
contrôlée, je
demande  un dernier
[Musique]
combat
Monica,
tu ne peux pas protéger ton
peuple mais tu peux rester chez toi sans
rester
seul, ils sont
[Musique]
ici les Marvels R
PG-13 uh-oh Monica tu dois voler non non non
magie de fille noire si Peters Frid  prends des billets maintenant
oh